look how beautiful my wife is she
dressed up as Belle for Beauty and the
Beast I am a lucky man Beauty and the
Beast of 2017 version is the remake of
the 1991 animated Disney classic which
itself was an adaptation of a very
famous French fairy tale and this
live-action version is the latest and
Disney successful adaptations of their
animated films after Cinderella their
Jungle Book Pete's dragon they're really
hitting a lot of home runs and I was
very curious to see what they could do
with this film because Beauty and the
Beast of 1991 version is one of my
favorites I grew up with this all of the
songs were imprinted into my head I
watched it over and over and over and it
might be my wife's favorite Disney
animation so there was a lot going into
this film that I was very excited about
if you don't know of course you have a
prince who was cursed because of his
selfish nature to live as a beast as
well as all of the members of his castle
they're now operating as clocks and
candlesticks and we have young Belle
played by Emma Watson who's obsessed
with books who gets trapped in his
castle and has to learn to love this
beast to hopefully reverse that spell
this film follows the original 1991
animation to almost a tee there are a
few new songs and a few extra scenes and
there's a few story elements that have
been changed and shifted around some
things to update to modern-day some
things that will appalled a lot of
parents today who are going to be upset
about certain portrayals of various
characters in this movie but for the
most part it maintains the original feel
of the animated classic and I had a
total blast with Beauty and the Beast I
think it's a very gorgeous film Bill
Condon directed this movie who in the
past has made a twilight movie but
there's really nothing that I can say
bad about the way the Twilight movies
are directed those movies are bad
because of the scripts his direction of
the Twilight films was about as good as
you could possibly expect when you're
handed that script and here he makes a
beautiful looking movie and a lot of
praise is to be given to the production
design this is a gorgeous looking movie
all of the costumes and the sets are so
glamour
everything looks absolutely stunning
there's CG present of course in this
movie there's quite a bit of it actually
but it's so well incorporated into the
real live-action elements that it felt
very seamless even the motion capture
work for the beast who is portrayed in
this movie by Dan Stevens who's one of
my favorite actors right now and I love
seeing him in anything he was really
great in this film I loved his portrayal
of the beast very sympathetic just like
he should be but at the same time you're
not really pitying him just because he
was cursed that's something they changed
in the animation they had him be a beast
since he was a child and he had
forgotten a lot about his past and
certain things had to be taught to him
again by Belle and that's kind of how
they grew to love one another in this
film he gets turned into a beast as an
adult and he retains his intellect
he's very literate he still loves books
and he has that connection with Belle
now and so they can share that love of
books and reading and knowledge together
and it's less of pitying Beast and
because of that pity Belle falls in love
with him it's a lot more mutual in this
film and that's something I think they
actually did improve upon the original
animation the prevalent songs that we
all grew up loving are still there in
the film and Emma Watson and Dan Stevens
and the entire cast did a very good job
at performing them I really love the
music it has the original composer from
the 91 films who came back to score this
one so that's great Luke Evans as Gaston
let's talk about him oh my god I loved
him as gaston he was so entertaining and
just a big oh if you seen the original
you know his character is lusting after
Belle and he's just a big hunk of the
town and Belle wants nothing to do with
him and he was perfect in this movie all
of the casting was just so on point here
kevin kline as Belle's father amazing
really fantastic performances all the
way around the music the set design the
performances the whole feel of it it was
all captured so well the film is very
much so a slave of the original it
follows its formula in every aspect from
scene to scene the songs are the same
the locations are the same the events
that happen are the same there's a few
extra little songs and a few extra
little scenes that weren't in
original animation and as I said they
tweaked a little bit of the character
motivations as well
but as a whole it's the exact same movie
just retold as live-action are you ok
with that
or were you hoping for something more
original that was completely different
in my opinion if it ain't broke don't
fix it I think the original Beauty and
the Beast is still an animated classic
and I'm glad they didn't just go in
there and try to do something insane and
change up the formula because I was
perfectly happy with what I got I think
this is a very marvelous Disney
live-action adaptation yet again they've
knocked it out of the park
I'm going to give Beauty and the Beast
and a - guys thank you so much as always
for watching I hope you like this video
and as always if you like this you can
click right here and get stuff mine eyes
[Music]